all right so I am going to just jump in
I have a lot of content I'm hopefully
going to get through most or all of it
fake news misinformation political
propaganda information war in the in the
last couple of years we've been
introduced to a lot of new terms not
always new oh we've been introduced to a
several terms that I tend to describe
some of the toxicities that we've been
perceiving in our information spaces and
I'm gonna focus on a subsection of this
problem and on one term in particular
disinformation and I'm going to talk to
you about it in the context that we've
been studying it online during crisis
events we've been looking at this
information for several years now but we
didn't start out with the intent to
focus on it like many online users these
days we just kind of stumbled into it
stumbled down the rabbit hole my first
line of research was examining digital
volunteerism during crisis events how
volunteers organized themselves using
online tools to help people during
natural disasters man-made disasters and
political protest events in 2013 my
collaborators and I set out to study
online rumors during crisis events and
in late 2015 early 2016 we began to
realize that we weren't just looking at
accidental rumors and misinformation we
were seeing pervasive disinformation
and that soon became the focus of our
research I've got a few different goals
for this talk mostly I want to try to
help you understand what disinformation
is and how it works I'm gonna situate
the term in some historical context I'm
going to provide some recent case
studies of on of online disinformation
I'm gonna use those to correct some
myths and perceptions some
misperceptions and add some nuance to
help us understand really how
disinformation works and finally I'm
going to talk to you about some
implications for the design of
Technology and policy around and
platform policy in particular around
this information the first thing I want
to do is distinguish between
misinformation and disinformation the
differences between the two are
especially important when we start to
think about solutions one high-level way
to characterize the distinction is
simply as a matter of intent
misinformation is information that is
false but not necessarily deliberately
so and disinformation is intentionally
false information from a high level I
think the
definition works this is the one I give
my undergraduate students in my class
but in another view disinformation isn't
simply about intent the term
disinformation has other more specific
meanings a historical context it's been
used to describe a particular kind of
political propaganda that's been
connected to Vista term desin format sia
originating in Soviet intelligence our
understanding of disinformation is
informed by the work of Ladislav bitman
who was a practitioner of soviet
disinformation a member of Czech
intelligence he defected the United
States in 1968 and became a professional
professor of disinformation studies as
he called him much of what we know about
the historical use of disinformation we
learned from him borrowing from Bittman
we defined disinformation as a suite of
tactics applied by influence agents to
manipulate information spaces to achieve
strategic political objectives it's
important to note that not all
disinformation historical or modern is
connected to Russia I think that's
really important especially right now in
the election context of the US however
Russia has been innovators in this space
and we're going to appreciate them for
for some of their innovation and I'm
going to present three case studies of
online disinformation two with actually
very strong connections to Russia's
intelligence and influence apparatus and
another that's a bit more tenuously
connected which I'll talk about as we go
these were long term studies that took
place over the course of multiple years
within our lab and I'm going to look at
these US studies through a CSE w
computer-supported cooperative work kind
of perspective looking at disinformation
is a kind of collaborative work between
agents not the agents we think about in
computer science but between influence
agents and crowds in our lab we apply a
socio technical lens exploring the
relationship between social and
technical structure and action how
technology the technologies that many of
you build how technology social norms
and social behavior are mutually
structuring and through this lens in
this work we focus on the collaborative
aspects of an inherently complex system
studying how diverse and distributed
groups of people connect and work
together towards various outcomes
intentional and otherwise and how that
activity is shaped by the environments
they work within and the norms and socio
technical structures that in turn take
shape
you're gonna hear a little of this
language as I go talking about shaping I
hope to bring some of it together but
you might have to read our recent paper
or see a CW paper that's coming out soon
to get more insight into kind of how
those things work together but this
perspective also informs our
methodological approach and our methods
are likely why why I'm here today why I
ended up being an expert of
disinformation which was not my
intention at all our work builds off of
methodological innovation in crisis
informatics our methods are profoundly
mixed we conduct iterative qualitative
and quantitative interpretive analysis
of big and small social data and other
online content we look at the data from
different perspectives using high-level
quantifications and visualizations to
see patterns and anomalies in the data
but also willing being willing and
anxious to roll up our sleeves and dive
into the data to analyze by hand
thousands of data points of content we
repeatedly go back and forth between
views at ten thousand feet and tweet by
tweeting speaking of tweets to some
extent all three of our case studies are
cross-platform studies but the seed data
for all of them was Twitter data because
that data has been public and that has
huge implications about what we know
about disinformation and we can talk
about some of that at the end hopefully
all right so I'm going to jump into
these case studies it's going to be a
lot of information all at once and
hopefully I'm going to bring some of it
back around at the end to kind of show
you how these case studies inform our
understanding of disinformation the
first case study is on Russian
interference in the 2016 US election
this week we heard about another report
from the US Senate Intel committee
reinforcing the now established claims
of interference in our case as I said
before we didn't set out the study
disinformation we were actually
initially studying framing in this study
we were studying framing contests in
black lives matter discourse primarily
between black lives matter activists who
were advocating against systemic and
justice and police violence against
African Americans and a counter movement
of conservative accounts that attempted
to challenge and denigrate the black
lives matter message this conversation
was highly polarized from data collected
relating to shooting events in 2016 we
generated a data set of tweets that had
either black lives matter or blue lives
matter in the text as part of the
work we created a structural graph of
retweets in the data in this graph each
node or circle is an account and the
accounts are clustered together when
they retweeted each other and further
apart when they didn't the edges here
are retweets but they're invisible in
this view the graph revealed two
separate communities our echo chambers
on either side of the conversation pro
blacklivesmatter on the left where the
accounts were mostly politically
left-leaning
or liberal and anti black lives matter
on the right where accounts were
consistently politically right leaning
or conservative when people talk about
online polarization this is what it
looks like structurally the two sides
created and spread very different frames
about police shootings of
african-american citizens at times the
discourse was emotional divisive and
honestly uncomfortable for our research
team we managed to complete this study
in October 2017 it was a CSC W paper a
few weeks later in November Twitter
released a list of accounts associated
with the internet research agency or IRA
in Saint Petersburg Russia which was
running disinformation operations online
during that time targeting us
populations
I saw a link to that list one night I
think the day that they released it in a
tweet because that's what I was doing at
night and I went to take a look looking
it over I instantly recognized some of
the accounts we'd featured a couple of
them in examples in our black lives
matter paper their handles were in our
tables their tweets were in our text I
sent my students who thankfully weren't
hanging out on Twitter to take a look at
the list as well they decided to
cross-reference that list with our graph
graph and to see where the IRA trolls
were in the conversation and this might
not surprise you now but it actually did
surprise us that this is that graph the
trolls the troller counter in orange
retweets of the trolls are also mapped
as orange lines connecting the retweet
er with the troll this graph reveals
Russian disinformation agents were
active on both sides of the black lives
matter conversation a few were among the
most influential accounts in the
conversation an orange account on the
left was retweeted by Jack at Twitter
and me several orange accounts on the
right had integrated into other
grassroots online organizing effort
on the conservative side perhaps through
follow back mechanisms my PhD student
Emmer arief conducted in-depth
qualitative it was also integral in this
earlier research both the black lives
matter framing and the graphing he
conducted in-depth qualitative research
on the accounts in orange he found that
the IRA accounts enacted
multi-dimensional online personas across
platforms that played on stereotypes of
african-americans on one side and white
us conservatives on the other they were
impersonating activists and also
modeling for others what activism what
online activism looked like reflecting
norms but to some extent shaping them
often their content wasn't superficially
problematic or even any different from
what others in the space we're doing
they were tweeting about strong black
voices on the left or support of US
veterans on the right
they were cultivating audiences for
future strategic messaging in other
places they were sowing and amplifying
division some of their content was among
the most vitriolic content in the space
advocating for violence against police
on the left and using racial epithets on
the right in a few cases we can see them
holding arguments with themselves like a
puppeteer having one of their accounts
on the Left fight with one of their
accounts on the right we now have a much
more complete view of the IRA activity
in 2018 through their projects sunlight
Twitter released all of the tweets from
the IRA accounts that they had
identified as part of this operation in
total they found more than 3000 accounts
and those accounts sent about three
million tweets in English which is which
is this graph here so if there's a
temporal graph of this activity the
retweets are down here oh sorry the
tweets are down here in the brighter
color and the retweets are up there in
the darker gray what you can see here is
that for years the IRA troll accounts
toiled in relative obscurity
they picked up few retweets and they had
few followers but that all began to
change around December 2015 and that was
right after they began to establish
those political personas that we had
accidentally found in our study these
political personas african-american
black lives matter activists which will
be blue on the next graft you
see and us white conservatives which
should be read on the next graph you see
when they began to perform these
personas their account started finally
to gain traction to get retweets and
follows nearly 85% of their retweets
that the IRA accounts received in total
were retweets of less than three hundred
accounts dedicated to the political
personas that we showed above in other
words the IRA trolls the disinformation
operations were most effective not in
spreading fake news which is one of
their other things that they did but in
infiltrating online political
communities stepping back what you can
see here is a multi-year campaign to
infiltrate and shape political discourse
in the United States orchestrated by a
group with ties to the Russian
government and we can see them burrowing
into and working within and in some
cases with otherwise organic online
communities to spread their narratives
to achieve their the agents goals we can
categorize this activity as orchestrated
which is going to contrast with some of
our upcoming example upcoming examples
it was coordinated by a single
organization inside a building in st.
Petersburg we don't know how much we
don't know much about how they worked
although we do have a couple of accounts
of people who infiltrated and came out
however we can assumed assume for the
most part that it was formally organized
and another way sorry I'm going to get
to that wait I'm gonna skip that one so
so the important thing here is is to
think about this this is one this isn't
an effort that was it was orchestrated
and it's going to contrast a little bit
to what we see next so the second case
study looks at disinformation during
armed conflict since 2017 this is going
to be a huge shift and it's gonna be a
little heavy so I apologize
since 2017 we'd been conducting research
on online discourse related to the civil
war in Syria in this research we focused
on conversations surrounding the work of
the serious civil defense also known as
the white helmets a volunteer rescue
group that works in rebel-held areas of
Syria this group does search and rescue
and provides medical aid to people
impacted by the civil war there the
white helmets also it's important they
also document those impacts often
calling out the impacts of air strikes
by Syria
Russian allies and atrocities such as
chemical weapons attacks the tweet above
that I just added a recent one
specifically calls out the Assad
regime's Russian allies and claiming
they specifically target aid workers the
white helmets content like this and
other and other tweets and videos that
they've created has served to some
extent to garner solidarity with and
simply sympathy for the Syrian people
from Western audiences in 2016 they were
the focus of an oscar-winning
documentary which likely catalyzed a
little bit of the content that we see
next which is a campaign against them in
2017 2018 when we started studying this
conversation if you searched Twitter or
Google for white helmets you may have
found some tweets supporting them but
most likely you would have encountered
content like this content that
challenges the white helmets claimant
that their propaganda construct of the
West ik weighting them with terrorists
or calling them crisis actors in our
research in this conversation we began
as we always do with a collection of
tweets that contained in this case the
term white helmets from a larger
connection a collection related to Syria
this is one representation of that data
set in the center of this graph is a
retweet network graph of that
conversation the accounts are sized by
the number of retweets they received and
they're connected to other accounts that
retweeted them and again you can see
this sort of polarization there's two
sides to the conversation using a
community detection algorithm we
identified two major major clusters of
accounts in this conversation Pro white
Pro white helmets accounts in blue and
anti white helmets accounts in red or
pink as you can see the red cluster is
dominating this conversation their
activity is persistent over time many of
the same accounts repeatedly tweeting
and retweeting content that specifically
attacks the white helmets they are
literally drowning out the voices of the
other side so who are these accounts on
the right that are dominating this
conversation the top influencers include
self-described journalists that
consistently produce content aligned
with Syrian and Russian government
interests
there are also officials from the Syrian
government and other governments in the
space and there are a few of what seemed
to be inauthentic
or likely paid or organizationally
controlled troll accounts so those are
all in there in some cases they're in
their influencers
but in authentic troll accounts make up
a tiny percentage of the overall content
in this space most of these people are
either journalists who are who they say
they are or what we would call sincere
activists we didn't though we went
looking for them we did not find BOTS
contributing to this conversation in any
way and I would say that few of these
accounts were paid trolls most of the
counts in red are unaffiliated accounts
to identify as activists many have been
active in other political conversations
a large portion of them have treated
have tweeted pro-palestinian content in
the past they were part of another
online community that was organized
around that task many also identify as
anti-imperialist and anti-war things
that many of my students that are
studying this might have used to
describe themselves and still do these
are real people who are sincere
believers of the content they're sharing
and many of them look a lot like us and
what are they doing they're
participating in what looks very much
like online activism they share articles
and videos that support their narratives
they mention each other a lot they
whistle and collectively dogpile content
that supports the white helmets I should
know that's how I first encountered them
I'd put up like an image of the
different media where that were involved
in this conversation and I just got all
of a sudden dog piled like I had never
been before by by handles that I would
soon recognize in my data but didn't yet
at the time so these accounts these
activists are persistent they tweet
about the right white helmets for months
years they activated opportune times to
capitalize on new information that can
help them make their case and just
distract from breaking news events that
are not aligned with their narratives
and they organize in many ways they look
like the online disaster volunteers I
used to study using Twitter and other
platforms to coordinate and collaborate
to recruit new members to spread their
messages this is very much collaborative
work they used some of the same
techniques that I'd been studying from
disaster volunteers in after the Haiti
earthquake in 2010 although their
techniques are a lot more advanced and a
little bit savvy or nowadays alright so
switching a little bit to a different
part of the structure of what's
happening here
around the outside of this graph is
actually a different kind of node these
are web domains or web sites that are
linked to from the tweets shared by
accounts in the center part of the graph
the
domains are size relative to the number
of tweets that they that link to each
and their colored according to the
proportion of tweets coming from the red
and blue sides of the graph you can see
here that YouTube is the most most
prominent URL that we have in our data
this is the domain that cited the most
it was a resource for the anti white
helmets content that was going on in red
and that activity we are still unpacking
that so I don't have a lot of results
there on that but it is something that's
very interesting in this conversation
but I want to focus on this part of the
graph here two of the top domains that
support this conversation are RT
formerly Russia today and Sputnik news
both domains are part of Russia the
Russian government's media and influence
apparatus in the white helmets
conversation these news domains provide
content including video content of the
conflict and interviews as interviews
with voices that share their objectives
they shape narratives they amplify
voices of anti white helmets influencers
they repeatedly interview the
journalists who are among the most
retweeted in this conversation and other
influencers often these influencers then
link back to their interviews or
entirety this sort of cross-platform
promotion and it actually moves over to
YouTube as well they're doing sort of
cross-platform promotion in some ways to
try to make their content look bigger
and broader than than it is and so we
kind of see this influence of the
Russian government in this larger
conversation there are other domains in
pink that function as a kind of gray
propaganda consistently repeating the
same kind of narratives we see on Artie
and Sputnik in some cases the same anti
white helmets articles appear across all
of these different or many of these
different domains at once that's another
paper I'm not gonna have time to go into
that here but we'd studied that as well
so when we step back here this is a
persistent campaign of at least
partially organic political activism
supported by the Russian government's
media apparatus and the Syrian regime as
well and in light and in and in an
alignment with their strategic
objectives it's not orchestrated in the
same way that we saw above it's more
cultivated the Russian information
apparatus amplifies friendly voices
provides a platform for journalists
whose stories aligned with their
narratives and lifts their profiles they
host content on their flagship site
sites but they also allow their content
blow through these various great
propaganda sites and they encourage
their viewers to question more while
spreading dozens of narratives that is
attempt to sow doubt about who the white
helmets are and what they do alright so
I'm gonna move on to the third case
study this one is not as practice as the
other two so I might stumble through it
a little bit it's a little bit older
this was actually our first paper on
disinformation was about this but I'm
putting it last because it shows a
different kind or different state of a
disinformation campaign and we've
actually been looking at this
conversation for a long time so in 2013
when we first embarked on our studying
studies of online rumery the first event
we looked at was the 2013 Boston
Marathon bombings this is a tweet sent
from the same day as as the bombings
maybe 18 hours later I think the Boston
bombing smells like a CIA black ops
false-flag set up again don't be fooled
by the mainstream media lies I'm
laughing because nowadays it's like oh
yeah like when we first put this up
they're like well that's so weird and
now we hear these same things all the
time because they're so they're so
pervasive so for us when we first
encountered this it was a it was part of
a strange rumor well that was very
different than the other rumors we were
studying it claimed that the event
hadn't happened as the media was
describing but that it was a false flag
that was really perpetrated by the CIA
over time across other events that we
were studying we kept seeing this same
kind of rumor an event after event after
event they would say that it was a false
flag with hidden perpetrators or that it
was a hoax event staged by crisis actors
each new event spawned a new round of
conspiracy theorizing though the same
themes came up again and again Western
governments are targeting their own
people the media is lying to you what
any same thing so we could see the same
there's but each time a new event would
kind of spawn a new way of new evidence
that they would tie into these sort of
old theories one thing that always
interest us about this from the very
first time we did this study was that
the strange websites that they cited
this was to be honest
these were better days but this was the
first time I encountered Infowars was in
my my 2013 all of us we were hand coding
these things and we're like what is in
for words and we went there and I'm sure
computers were never the same but it
wasn't just in for worse Artie was in
these places a year newswire veterans
today activists post these these
websites with with weird names and it
was just it looked very different
so we mapped out this space using user
code sharing patterns where the nodes or
web domains connected when the same user
tweets links to both sites and this is
kind of a view of that map I don't have
a lot of time to unpack it but
essentially the sites in Reds red here
were the ones that supported the
conspiracy theorizing and explicitly
contain content mentioning these
conspiracy theories of crisis events the
sites in blue tried to actively debunk
these conspiracy theories I'm not sure
it worked but they tried in the sites in
yellow were actually brought into the
conversation by people citing their
articles as evidence for their
conspiracy theory but though the sites
in yellow in this case weren't
specifically mentioning so they were
part of the diet of a person who might
be conspiracy theorizing but not
necessarily explicitly sharing a
conspiracy theory in this case so after
the creating the graph here I conducted
content analysis of the different web
domains I dove into the red side of that
graph I don't necessarily recommend that
it took me a couple years I feel like
I'm finally recovered after a month or
two of sabbatical and and putting this
all behind me but it was it's really it
was really disorienting that analysis
revealed this ecosystem to be supporting
a variety of different conspiracy
theories and pseudo scientific claims
they were critical Western governments
they were anti media anti science the
content consistently reflected populist
ideologies and anti-semitic themes it
also contained many and diverse claims
about powerful people controlling world
events a sort of all-encompassing
conspiracy theory through which each new
event could be interpreted another thing
we noticed was the presence of state
controlled media and think tanks within
primarily the red areas of the graph
these websites were resources for people
sharing this content again amplifying
and shaping their views interestingly
that that ecosystem I just showed you
has a various
drawing overlap with the media ecosystem
supporting the anti way to helmets
discourse in our other study and I could
overlay that but again not enough time
so this wasn't orchestrated but organic
strategically cultivated sometimes and
amplified when useful by by Russian
Russian and other actually Russia isn't
the only one there's Iranian outlets in
the space and and others as well but
they weren't they weren't doing the
conspiracy theorizing the activity may
be loosely tied to state-run
disinformation but what actually happens
is that that that people in in in the
online communities are now so sort of
embedded having this kind of
epistemology or way of thinking about
the world that when they see new
information they begin to in a new event
they begin to interpret it through these
same kinds of themes and so for each new
event they generate new theories based
on these old themes explaining the event
as another example of a grand conspiracy
of powerful people manipulating events
and where the mainstream media lies to
covers for them they then assembled the
evidence for new each new event into a
new conspiracy theory we can often see
them discussing this with discussing
sorry discussing shifting the theory
over time to adapt to new evidence
trying to find the theory with the best
fitness to spread beyond their community
they'll argue but no it's not a false
flag it's a hoax event this time the
community doesn't need any priming to
run with to run with a deep state
elective about the 2016 election
interference they had been playing with
some similar narratives for years in
some cases decades these theories often
start out organically but they're they
can be amplified strategically and what
we've actually started to notice which
is one of the things that was so
disorienting to us early and kind of
pushed us into this line of research was
that these conspiracy theories and these
ways of thinking and talking about
things started to spread to influencers
media influencers and actually political
leaders not just in the US but in other
places so this conspiracy theorizing has
begun to be mainstreamed and in certain
ways we can see how deep state theories
have found fertile ground in this kind
of kind of epistemic community and an
overlap and narratives such
the queue none if you've heard of that
is an extension or expansion or a
relative of this kind of epistemic
community alright so case studies those
are our three case studies you can see
there's different kinds we've got
orchestrated activities sort of
cultivated activity and organic activity
we can also think of those as maybe
different stages or the orchestrated
activity that we saw in the black lives
matter was an early stage of a
disinformation campaign this the Syria
case the white helmets case is more of a
mid-level stage where they're still
actively cultivating and the conspiracy
theorizing of crisis events is something
that almost has it has a self-sustaining
in many ways alright so I'm going to use
some of the material from these studies
to revisit our understanding of
disinformation to share a couple of
things about we've learned about how it
works and why we're vulnerable and why
solutions aren't so simple so
disinformation is not simply false
information and sometimes it isn't false
at all to be effective disinformation
layers truth with lies often building on
a true or plausible core but then adding
new details and omitting others to shape
a specific narrative towards a strategic
specific strategic objective in the IRA
troll case the troll accounts mislead
their audiences about who they were and
what their intentions and motivations
were they attempted to shape political
discourse and political action in that
case voting the trolls pushed Donald
Trump messages on the right and
anti-clinton messages on the left so
they were trying to shape this sort of
political action of the communities they
infiltrated towards objectives that
those communities those communities
themselves may not have been aware of
and might not have shared in the White
House case we can see narratives like
this one built from factual information
so the white helmets do receive funding
from Western governments and they and
they have advertised that and they have
you know there's there have been white
helmets or volunteers that have done bad
things but according to act the
activists in pink use though that that
kind of evidence those kinds of things
to say that the media suicide attorney
to say that the white helmets are paid
by
Western governments to create propaganda
meant to change how people see the war
it's a compelling narrative that's hard
to privatize as simply true or false
its strategic another insight from this
work is that we need to consider or
reconsider our unit of analysis it's not
always too effective to think of this
information as a single piece of
information but instead we should think
of it as a campaign bitman used that in
that unit of analysis and borrowing from
his characterization and our analyses of
modern disinformation we agree that it's
useful to think of this information not
as a quality of a specific piece of
information but as a collection of
information actions or a campaign
looking at the 2016 election
interference in the United States we can
see a multi-channel multi-dimensional
campaign on the IRA side we talked about
Twitter but the trove account was
multi-platform Facebook Instagram Tumblr
commenting on web articles and forums
making and distributing playlists on
SoundCloud they were really profoundly
multi multi platform but it wasn't just
a social media campaign or just the IRS
and it's trolls it included the release
of stolen emails that have been
repeatedly associated with Russian
hackers the use of great propaganda
sites to push their narratives the
manipulation of mainstream media in the
West to spread their stolen content and
the infiltration of other social and
political organizations it's a campaign
it's all these things together in the
White House helmets example it's not
just a single piece of information or a
single narrative but an onslaught of
stories that built into several
connective narratives using YouTube and
Twitter and in combination with
connected media strategies across dozens
of great propaganda sites this effort
sought to undermine the white helmets
especially their efforts to garner
sympathy from global audiences but also
to connect them to terrorists on one
hand and narratives questioning Western
interfere intervention and challenging
Western media on the other I end with
one of the most recent narratives a
tweet featuring RT interview with a
prominent journalist in this space
Vanessa B Lee where she claims that the
white helmets are trafficking in the
organs of children and I'm going to
leave that there
for the case of conspiracy theories
theories of crisis events in part these
communities exist in a kind of
particular kind of information space or
disinformation space where the echo of
old campaigns can be heard within a
community that is developed an
epistemology or way of knowing that
renders them particularly vulnerable to
additional disinformation that aligns
with the meta narratives of past
disinformation campaigns perhaps these
reviews sort of the long-term effects of
pervasive disinformation I hope that
they aren't a sign of things to come
considering these two together as we
turn to questions of detection which
many of the the technology folks in the
room might be thinking about it's
important area of research especially in
online environments
this means that identifying
disinformation isn't about determining
the truth value of a specific post or
the authenticity of a single account but
we need to think about how that post an
account fit into a larger campaign where
the underlying attempt sorry the
underlying intent is to mislead for a
strategic political purpose in this view
disinformation remains disinformation
regardless of who the intermediary is a
person does not need to be aware of
their role in the campaign to be a
participant and this is very difficult
implications for technology companies
wanting to address the spread of
disinformation on their platforms
because it's far easy to problematize
and take action against paid trolls
than it is to silence sincere activists
which is absolutely something I do not
recommend right so this is a much more
difficult problem and this gets to the
point that we highlighted in the title
of this talk and I didn't really cover
it I'm still trying to figure out how to
edit how to push this in here but a lot
of the research it's not a criticism but
a lot of the research in this area is
focused on detecting or talking about or
detecting automated activity thoughts
and or inauthentic accounts or trolls
but this information isn't just about
BOTS and trolls as we can see in our
studies it targets infiltrates
cultivates shapes and ultimately
leverages online crowds and communities
Bittman talked about the role of
unwitting agents the role that they
played in historical disinformation
campaigns here we can see agents working
with are collaborating with unwitting
crowds to achieve their goals
I encourage researchers and platform
designers not just to focus on the
orange parts of the graph on the left
but to look at the blue and the pink on
the graph on the right to study how
online communities are targeted and
affected by disinformation how some
members of those unwitting crowds take
it up and make it their own
eventually generating their own
propaganda like messages that reflect
the narratives of the disinformation
operatives I want to underscore this we
have a tendency to think that
disinformation affects other people that
we're somehow smarter or severe or
something but I would contest that we
are all vulnerable to disinformation
this information works it is profoundly
disorienting
by design we experience that as
researchers in all of these spaces
disorientation not knowing what was true
but we could believe in what we couldn't
believe for the black lives matter
conversation the lead researcher on our
team Emer has talked extensively about
how hard it was to see the IRA content
on the left as propaganda because it
aligns so closely to his views in the
white helmets conversation it took our
researchers weeks and in some cases
months and in some cases I'm not sure
that one student ever finally came fully
back to recognize that what they were
seeing was disinformation much of the
content was targeted at people exactly
like us left-leaning critical of US
military intervention and from diverse
and many cases international backgrounds
things got easier for us when we began
to see the patterns of aunt of
information sharing and the connections
to the douches disinformation apparatus
but we were still left with lingering
doubt about the white helmets and their
mission which was the whole point they
didn't ever have to convince us that
they were all these horrible things but
they gave us just enough doubt that we
would not take action or ask our
political leaders to take action about
what was going out there on there so
we're all yes so we're all vulnerable
looking beyond a single campaign the
pervasive use of disinformation has
consequences for the societies
experiencing it one of those is
diminished trusted information we've
talked a lot about that here in
different ways
this information reduces our ability to
know whom or what to trust with the idea
that when people don't know where they
can go for information that they can
trust they can lose their agency we can
get back on our heels we don't know what
action we can take as we're not sure
what what's going on and we lose our
ability to take decisions based on a
knowledge of the world if we don't trust
our knowledge in that world you can see
in this example both the cause and the
effect here right the pervasive spread
of conspiracy theories that there's a
there's a you can't trust them this is a
direct attack they're saying don't trust
the mainstream media but it's also
reflecting this person doesn't trust the
mainstream media and this is we should
all be critical but this is a profound
like absolute distrust as if the
mainstream media is literally trying to
trick us is is their is their ideology
now and the IRA trolls played to this
distrust directly attacking media in the
US this is a tweet from one of the
prominent IRA troll accounts that which
is on the right in this case they were
on the rights that are the conservative
side of our graph this was sent in 2017
so after our collection period was shut
down but you can see them say CNN is
Isis right we actually saw that exact
same line as a hash tag in our Sirius
data set from some of the folks in pink
CNN is Isis right this profound distrust
of media but it's not just fake news or
mainstream media that we were told we
can't trust it's also about just about
anything you encounter online do you
think about the persistence of having
trolls in these conversations even
making those trolls known has this
effect to cause us not to trust what we
see in these online and spaces that
account you're arguing with just label
them a Russian troll and block them that
article with information that makes you
uncomfortable
that's just fake news you don't want to
believe that someone would take a gun
into a school inch and shoot children
just call it a hoax or a government
conspiracy when I first saw the images
of the notre-dame Cathedral on fire I
thought it was a deep fake right so we
lose our trust in information spaces and
this loss of trust feeds into a more
troubling point disinformation
undermines democratic societies it
destabilizes the common ground that we
need to stand
upon to govern ourselves it undermines
our shared reality we lose trust and
information in the converse in the
confidence that we know what we know and
that things are as they seem
notice the positioning of these orange
clusters on this graph on the outside of
these communities helping to pull these
communities further apart okay can't
can't measure that here but that sort of
suggested here it's empirical but it's
metaphorical the disinformation tears at
the social fabric amplifying existing
divisions as the division becomes too
extreme we can't come together to have
conversations to make change to govern
ourselves to change minds if we can't
come together we can't we can't have a
democracy democracy doesn't work and
then people can turn towards more
authoritarian leadership or at least
that's what we think we're seeing in
some spaces all right so I'm going to
shift to talking a little bit about
solutions and then opening up for
questions I want to start here that the
tactics and effects of disinformation
are resonating with features of socio
technical environments I use the word
resonance here purposefully I don't
think social media caused disinformation
they are in a single root cause of
what's going on in in the world they're
a factor things that are the way that
Tecna that these these socio technical
systems have taken shape have
highlighted some of our vulnerabilities
and a lot and become a vector of certain
kinds of disinformation attacks so show
me they didn't start this fire but
they've become the feel for it and
additionally because it's not simply
cause and effect we can't just engineer
our way out of it it's a complex problem
and solutions are going to be so simple
as a new design feature on our favorite
social media platform but that doesn't
mean we need to throw our hands up in
defeat I think this is really really
important so I was on a panel about a
year ago and we were just talking about
this information and every time someone
suggested a solution if I go that won't
work because of this so that won't work
because of that it's too hard were too
vulnerable everything's going wrong and
we didn't even realize how badly we were
I think we felt defeated but we were you
know expressing this defeatism and we
was in DC and this this guy stood up and
he
that you'd have been an ambassador I
actually don't know his name but a lot
of people there did I'm not a DC person
I should have but he stood up and this
guy had been around a long time
and he got up and he scolded us and he
said you know if we had this kind of
defeatism you know during the Cold War
or whatever we never would have solved
and people said you know this is
unsolvable and we've got this nuclear
threat and the world is going to blow up
and we just chipped away at the problem
from all of these different sides and
eventually we solved it and I have been
thinking a lot about that since then I
felt what chastised for good reason I
don't think that we're going to solve
all of this information the things that
we're seeing the toxicities that we're
seeing online or in the broader society
at all at once with a new tool or a new
law or a new digital literacy class it's
a hard problem but that doesn't mean we
need to give up in fact that's the last
thing we need to do we're not gonna
solve it all at once but we are gonna
solve it we're gonna solve it by
chipping it away we're gonna chip away
at all of these different ways we need
to you know think about new designs of
technology we need to think about new
ways of educating not just children but
all of us across K through 99 journalism
has a lot of work to do to make itself
more trustworthy there's good criticisms
the criticisms of journalism the
disinformation builds off of seeds of
truth right so it builds off of times
with journalism has made mistakes to to
amplify those and so journalism needs to
improve itself and and clearly we're
gonna have to talk about new policies I
want to I'm going to finish with this
I'm going to punt on the macro-level
policy right now we're governments are
going to put in policies I'm still
learning about that it's one of the
reasons I've bent Stanford this quarter
but I've talked here a little bit about
platform policy I have been in some
conversations around that so companies
like Facebook and Twitter increasingly
working on these policies they're
communicating about them they're putting
them in place to help address this
information and other forms of online
manipulation Facebook's been focused on
coordinated and authentic behavior I
think they're making some progress
they've got great people that are
working hard on hard problems they're
not always making decisions that we
agree with but I I do think that they're
there they're working on it however a
lot of these policy
including Facebook's idea of focusing on
coordinated inauthentic behavior
I think they fall short when we start to
think about the role of unwitting crowds
so platforms are going to have their
work cut out for them as they seek to
balance things like freedom of speech
with their inherent vulnerability to
manipulation we're a subset of actors
can manipulate the space to privilege
their messages over others we can also
see an issue so I guess from my policy
recommendations it's actually to kind of
think about our more nuanced view of
this information thinking about it as a
campaign that has a particular kind of
intent I think Facebook has been really
reluctant to promote eyes on intent and
I actually don't think that we can
address this information without
considering the intent of the campaign's
that we're looking at and when they had
when they're intended to mislead for
strategic political purpose I think
that's what they need to be
problematized and not on a unit of
analysis a post or an account but on
sort of a broader campaign and they need
to take action against the campaign even
if as it as it spreads down stream
through intermediaries that are further
and further away from the original
agents that spread it I don't know
exactly how they're going to do that but
that's what I would encourage them to do
and as they do that I think they're
faced with a challenge that we need to
appreciate and also kind of push them on
they call it working the refs and that
is that they're getting a lot of
political pressure whenever they try to
take action it's because I this is my
what I think is that there's a people
that are in power now perhaps people
have always been in power they've
benefited from the manipulation of these
platforms they benefit from the spread
of this information and they're gonna
claim that any attempt to address that
manipulation is biased or not neutral
but as many of us know especially if
you're in HCI
is that technology is neutral there's no
neutrality there are values embedded in
technology it's not right versus left
but there's a commitment to certain
kinds of values and I would encourage
the people that are developing platforms
for this sort of mass communication and
information sharing to think about the
value of supporting democratic discourse
of not allowing us to get pulled apart
and not having this Mis
information be so pervasive in our
spaces and I think I would encourage the
tech platforms to identify and own those
values of value like that perhaps and
anchor themselves and tell them that
values to grow roots or they risk
getting bowled over by these
disingenuous attacks that call them
biased and so with this call to own your
values as you're designing things I'm
going to end this say thank you also
thank a lot of my students and
collaborators who have helped with this
research and been foundational and open
this up for questions